hallo hier ist die wir vielleicht habt
ihr mit dem podcast gehört möchte ich
kurz von einem neuen feature erzählen
und zwar clips das ganze ist dafür da um
eure lieblings stellen aus ellis video
mit anderen zu teilen um das ganze
feature nutzen zu können müsst ihr euch
in eurem youtube account anmelden dann
auf ein video gehen und dort seht ihr
das symbol clips da geht hier einfach
drauf nehmt eure lieblings stelle aus
fast dem ganzen einen namen und dann
könnt ihr das ganze auf whats app
instagram oder auf jeder beliebigen
anderen plattformen mit dem bunten
treiben viel spaß beim ausprobieren und
schicken ihre teure clubs oft instagram